Welcome back everyone this is my new Eternals
trailer video for Kit Harington's black knight
character and Richard Madden's Ikaris character
along with Sersi, it sounds very familiar.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs in here kit
harington was also talking recently about
coming back in the Avengers movies like Avengers
5, other big marvel movies in the future,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos I'll be
doing a bunch more a Eternals videos in the
next month or so, because that's the next
big marvel movie this coming out and as you've
all seen the Eternals movie is something of
a game of thrones reunion for Kit Harington
Richard Madden because Robb Stark in Johnstone
never saw each other after game of thrones
season 1 episode 2 in the Eternals movie they
also have a not so friendly love triangle
competition for another character name Sersi.
Like I said I was he Gemma Chan's Sersi and
you spell Sersi a different way.
That it is funny how their last scene together
became the self fulfilling prophecy and see
them all in black he shall because kit harington
chose to join the Eternals movie as the black
knight Dane Whitman or future black knight
we should say because when the movie picks up
He believes that he's just a normal person
working at the natural history Museum with sersi's character
Not knowing that she's an eternal in not knowing
anything about the curse of his family or
the curse of the black knight.
But as you can see from the trailer Thanos
the events of Avengers infinity war.
The infinity gauntlet snap the many infinity
gauntlet snaps like the whole snapped the
blip Iron Man snap avengers endgame.
Everybody and their sister on planet Earth
knows about that now it's not a big secret.
So it's past in a common knowledge.
Like during falcon and winter soldier the
shang chi movie Spider-Man no way home the
spectacle of the blip the whole bring everyone
back has kind of worn off on the public the
way the Kit Harington's black knight character
finds out about the Eternals and finds out
about his heritage is the black knight his
family's legacy his ancestor was the original
Sir Percy version of the black knight in the
King Arthur chronicles her marvel's version
of the King Arthur stories many that within
the MCU King Arthur, Mordred, Morgana, Merlin
all those characters really would've existed
for the way he learns about all of this eternals
business is that he's involved in an attack
by the deviants would that she see the scene
in the trailer is the one here were Sersi
and spider standing in the street saving his
life from the bus.
That's about to run over him and turn him
into a pile of goo when Sersi transmutes the
matter into a bunch of flowers.
That's basically the power they're going with
for her in the movies.
She transmutes things into other things.
Like she turns the ground in the water earlier
in the trailer when she's helping ancient
humans learn to farm if it wasn't clear from
the scenes of Sprite in the trailer her ability
will be creating illusions click here.
She creates a bunch of copies of herself in
the street when they're saving Kit Harington's
character in a way that Loki creates illusions
will be a lot of similarities in their abilities
the way their powers work in the way that
modern MCU characters powers look and feel.
Even though the place were all their power
comes from is just regular celestial energy
is very similar to the celestial energy the
ego the living planet weilds the Peter Quill weilds
when he's near ego the living planet, but
is marvel's way of sort of connecting everything
in a sort of baselevel how you explain where
all these different powers come from.
But the whole idea in the movies of the deviants
hate humans.
They want to get rid of them by waking up
this giant celestials of the no basically
destroy the earth, but also on the DL you
can see deviants just randomly attacking people
all over the place so Kit Harington's character
Dane Whitman just happens to be in this place
when the deviants attack and they cause the
bus to crash.
Which is what causes Sersi to use her powers
to save him.
Which is her breaking the sacred rule given
to them by the celestials and Arishem the
judge this big red celestial here who they're
calling the prime celestial in the movie the
leader of the celestial host so he witnesses
them using their powers, then they have to
explain to him about their history and why
they didn't help with thanos during avengers
infinity war avengers endgame.
They have that seen in the trailer.
Like why did you guys help out in the whole
black knight ebony blade curse of his family
the armor and such that something that's uncovered
by the end of the movie.
Because he studies history for a living at
the natural history Museum the Eternals have
been chronicling human history collecting
artifacts for the last 7000 years.
So the would've been around to witness the
rise of his ancestor Sir Percy the original
Black Knight and they know all about the curse
of his family in the curse of the ebony blade
is actually the blade that's cursed.
It's not Dane Whitman himself.
The ebony blade is an artifact kind of like
the staff of the living tribunal in the doctor
strange movie in item imbued with incredibly
powerful magic.
But getting to the big internal conflict between
Kit Harington's Dane Whitman and Richard Madden
sticker is character obviously Ikaris isn't
meant to be a bad character is meant to be
one of the leaders of the Eternals.
Like Salma Hayek's age at character.
Even though technically she's kind of like
their big sister the unofficial leader of
the group when it comes to fighting abilities
Ikaris is just looked at is one of the most
powerful internals even though technically
Gilgamesh is supposed to be the strongest
eternal like you're talking about brawling
strength strongest avenger strongest avenger.
But there big conflict is over their love
triangle with Sersi's character.
So in the context of the MCU timeline within
the movies eternal's are created by the celestials.
Like this in the trailer about 7000 years
ago as human looking copies imbued with celestial
energy they didn't start out as humans.
Like the comic book version the Eternals the
celestials.
Kind of made them like you would create vision
or even Ultron.
Like living humanoid robots powered by celestial
energy and soft programs down to their DNA
hunt deviants and protect the celestial that's
growing inside planet Earth.
That's part of the reason why that has so
much trouble intervening in human history
not saving anyone during huge natural disasters
or Avengers infinity war avengers endgame.
Because they're literally programmed to not
help out so part of their arc during the movie
is them finally being able to rebel against
that rebel against the celestial host under
threat of annihilation to because of the celestials
don't like an experiment that they created
the just wipe it from existence.
What you see east on the searcher using the
power stone to just wipe out an entire planet.
Like you know what will just start over again.
But the Eternals are literally robots they
have all the same organs and tissue bodily
structures as humans.
It just that the celestials 3D printed them
using their technology and celestial energy
empowering them such that through their technology
they will never die in the comics, the way
they achieve this though, is through celestial
reincarnation technology that replaces their
bodies if they get killed see you can kill
them.
Like they have organic tissue, but they're
functionally immortal because they just reincarnate
in new bodies may change that a little bit
for the movie.
But that's kind of what you see happening
here when they're sitting around this giant
statue of Arishem the judge this giant red
crystal that looks like him.
But after their created 7000 years ago sent
earth on their mission Ikaris in Sersi fall
in love and have this relationship.
The just last for thousands and thousands
of years.
But eventually the deviants activity wanes
and there aren't any big threats for a long
period of time and things slow down so much
for the Eternals that they all just started
drifting apart and chilling out.
So when the events of the movie pickup none
of the Eternals have seen each other, including
Ikaris in Sersi for hundreds and hundreds
of years.
And in the centuries since they sort of drifted
apart since they kind of broke up Sersi has
started a relationship with Dane Whitman in
present day Kit Harington's character.
So Richard Madden's Ikaris coming back is
kind of like the ex-boyfriend ex-husband coming
back to town with them being brought together
by this great calamity the emergence that's
going to happen in the next seven days with
the new celestial sort of bursting at a planet
Earth unless they can do something about it.
Like I said the Eternals are trying to save
humanity find a way to prevent this from happening
or prevent the celestial host also from destroying
planet Earth.
But the deviants led by this character Kro
who you see with Angelina Jolie's Thena character.
He wants the celestial inside earth to hatch
so that it will destroy all humans the sort
of the push pull of the movie in against the
backdrop of this, you have Kit Harington's
Dane Whitman character learning about his
heritage as the black knight and then through
future marvel movies becoming like the full-blown
version of the black knight when they talk
about him coming back in Avengers five other
future marvel movies that just them adapting
a version of his comic book story during the
1980s he and Sersi had this run where they
join the avengers literally like they actually
join one of the avengers teams they had slightly
different looking costumes.
Because it was the 1980s obviously that'll
be a little bit different for the MCU movie
version but if you saw Kit Harington talking
about coming back and more marvel movies recently.
That's what he was referring to ever done
a much longer video about kit harington's
black knight character how his powers work
with history of his family is.
So a link that video at the end of this and
down in the description.
They did have a small Easter egg for the black
knight character during Spider-Man far from
home when they go into the Tower of London
because obviously the King Arthur mythology
the black knight character came from that
area in human history is a suit of armor that
belong to one of his ancestors in the tower
when they run into try and escape Mysterio's
drones the other big things they're doing
with the Eternals movie is also setting the
next stage for how they explain mutants in
the MCU in the background sort of laying Easter
eggs until you actually see legit mutants
big X-Men characters popping up.
I just did a big video about that you can
click here to learn how they're setting up
mutants inside the MCU.
And you can click here for that longer kit
harington black knight Eternals video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you in the next video!